[Music]
[Applause]
akanchha Thomas a juicer or jet a Dodger
no la paz Ababa a infidel trauma
branches NATO paparazzo preview Matt no
stipulation relish viola Roma pal Roger
a deficit Kosuke media laapcha schedule
s'appelle Lakota trees sol la una FATA a
supersonic jet a Tommy la France a
country
Salaf a photo Rio cotton polo single a
Pascal sanae's amis arrived a doughnut
AR Sosa planet Reza dr. Aldo muchos miss
Sheridan Capriccio a madam miss chin-hua
serve well des amis Isabel
Monsieur Madame party Doha Joshua
espect are depicted on a location are
delicious miss Coco interpret a donor
gotta be Maria retreat yo remember only
a premiere of our presentation ramappa
on Prozac la - merciless a and I know
Rizzuto's respect that Ric Bucher
enthusiasm a book could play Syria we
arrived heart a huge fire bridge a
double donation or basis upon wha a
smoker I knew that the train station was
somewhere near and if something is I am
an actor and I have autism it's really
hard for people with any disability to
get a large role in a professional
theatre but for the first time in my
life I'm getting to star in a major
professional production
you said it was September 12th last year
at first Frank my name is Mickey Rowe
and I am playing Christopher Boone in
the Curious Incident of the dog in the
night-time the Curious Incident of the
dog of the night time is about a boy who
has autism and his adventure that flips
his world upside down I am the first
autistic actor to play Christopher Boone
and I am surprisingly one of the first
autistic actors to play any autistic
character anywhere I've had to be an
actor my whole life to pass as
neurotypical so being an actor comes so
naturally to me
I used scripting in my daily life for
example if I went to a coffee shop I
might say to the barista hi can I please
have a medium drip coffee how's your day
going today has it been busy today
and then regardless of what they say
it's been busy or slow I can then say oh
would do you like it better when it's
busier when it's slow so that way I can
kind of script my life so I don't have
to deal with social interactions thank
you so much have a great rest of your
day
[Applause]
in rehearsal is my happy spot because I
have the lines I'm playing a character
everyone else is playing a role be it
another character in the player director
during five-minute breaks or 10-minute
breaks or lunch breaks is when you feel
less comfortable you don't have a
specific role during that time which
makes it confusing for someone on the
spectrum on stage there's often bright
light shining on you and loud noises
that come out of nowhere as sound cues
but you've rehearsed all these things in
advance and you know where each sound
cue is happening because it happens in
the exact same place every night so it
almost feels like you're in control of
those things and because you know what
to expect you're in on the magic you
would have to talk to other people
though from Mission Control but we would
do that your radio link up in a TV
monitor it's so rare for any actor with
any disability to get to play a leading
role in any production let alone a
professional traveling production I get
to show people that people with
disabilities we get the job done
[Applause]
you
when I was 26 years old I began losing a
lot of hair I was terrifying but I
wouldn't change a thing about how
everything is unfolded my name is
Anthony Carrigan I'm an actor and I have
alopecia alopecia areata
is a it's an autoimmune disorder in
which your body thinks that something's
wrong with it and so it attacks the hair
follicles and and because of that you
lose patches of hair I was very shy as a
kid when I first started acting I began
to kind of discover this voice within
myself so when I lost a lot of my hair I
had no idea what to do
I didn't know if I could still be an
actor I didn't know if I could remain in
this business that was so so image
focused but then I found something
within me that was worth fighting for I
found a whole new perspective on the way
that I looked I found a whole new
perspective on what kind of characters I
could play and I began to cultivate that
I have been typecast as as the villain I
think it isn't just me bald guys
throughout history have played the
villain some of the TV shows that I've
been in I was on an episode of the
blacklist the flash CW Gotham on Fox for
the longest time I tried to kind of
create a certain self that didn't have
alopecia because a lot of the time we
feel like we need to put on a face and
that's just not real it's all about
being human and it being okay to not be
perfect
[Music]
you
I've been shot on the street stabbed in
prison been a victim of a slashing twice
actually dead in the morgue died in a
supermarket from overeating my name is
Ali Murray
I am a actor and I have played a dead
body on several occasions the director
usually tells you to hold still try your
best to hold your breath it's good to
slow your breathing down beforehand kind
of like yoga or meditation played a
corpse in the morgue on Law & Order
laying down on cold metal while you know
you're practically wearing nothing is
it's bone-chilling and to say the least
you can take short breaths but they
still don't want to see your chest going
up and down at a distance they're like
in a second you sure that guy's been
back there he's breathing
whenever you end up dying on camera or
playing dead on camera it brings you to
another emotional state normally people
don't think if I was shot or stabbed
what would I do but once you're there
and you're playing it it's kind of a
little traumatic you feel bad for people
when you see real people get hurt you
take it in a different you know you see
it in a different way you know my kids
watch it sometimes and they're like dad
you're dead
they killed you like no I'm here with
you now I'm okay
[Music]
when my ticks come on I don't really
have a defense against it and sometimes
it just sort of comes out in these
explosive spontaneous ways and I'm an
actor with Tourette's for a long time I
did worry about exposing that cuz I
thought it would affect getting hired
auditions whatever it might be now I
just put it on the table it feels great
to own it
my show is about having Tourette's
syndrome and finding my own way with it
Tourette's syndrome is a neurological
disorder that you're born with the
stereotype about Tourette's is that
people will curse uncontrollably which
people do I've never done that when I
tick I clear my throat I cough sometimes
I make noises in my throat huh so
welcome they use that if you want
yeah riding this subway is rough I still
get nervous about it especially since I
have this throat clearing the sniffing
tic I have Tourette syndrome if I'm
making that noise
when I'm acting I don't tick somehow I'm
like in this zone and I'm able to just
focus it kind of just like goes away and
it says okay take a break do what you
love and I'll be waiting for you when
you come back
[Music]
[Music]